-Welcome back, everybody.
Here at "The Tonight Show,"
We love stand-up comedy
and we especially love stand-up
written by our audience members
in under an hour.
That's right. It's time for a
battle of the instant stand-ups.
Here we go.
-♪ Battle of the instant
stand-ups ♪
-Welcome to "Battle
of the Instant Stand-ups."
Before the show,
we went through our audience
and picked out two people
who said they were comedians.
We gave them each a topic
and then gave them an hour
to write an original stand-up
set based on that topic.
They've never performed it.
Here they are preparing
backstage a minute ago.
Yeah. You can't unsee that.
Now, let's see what they came up
with and meet them right now.
Come on over, everybody.
Guys, come on out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nice to see you.
Nice to see you. Pleasure.
Hi. Nice to see you.
Welcome to the show.
Now, let's start
with contestant number one.
What is your name
and where are you from?
-I'm Nat Towson, and I'm
from Manhattan, New York.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey! From Manhattan, New York.
I love that.
-Nat, what was the topic
that you were given tonight?
-Saint Patrick's Day.
-Okay, and are you Irish?
Or we'll find out, I guess.
-I'm not.
-Yeah. Interesting.
And you've never performed
this in front of a crowd?
You just wrote this?
-Yeah.
-This is very exciting.
Alright, well, head
on over to the stage.
Get in your headspace.
Nat.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is exciting. I love this.
And now, ladies and gentlemen,
here to perform
a brand-new comedy
set about Saint Patrick's Day,
Please give it up
for Nat Towson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you. Thank you.
I just got back from Europe.
I know I look like
I was about to say that.
[ Laughter ]
I learned that in Ireland,
Saint Patrick's Day is actually
not a big deal at all.
They already have a day
when everyone drinks.
It's called Monday.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Last year, I spent
Saint Patrick's Day
with 3,000 drunk idiots
in Midtown Manhattan.
-Whoo!
-No place has been
that disrespectful
to the Irish since England.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's true. The English
hate redheads so much,
they don't even like
Prince Harry.
[ Laughter ]
And everyone in Midtown
was dressed
in traditional
Celtic Mardi Gras beads...
[ Laughter ]
...and a T-shirt that said,
"I-rish you were naked."
[ Laughter ]
I-rish I was making that up.
And everyone was wearing green,
so you couldn't even tell
which frat they were in.
[ Laughter ]
And then they all
scurried off to New Jersey...
[ Laughter ]
...like the snakes fleeing
Ireland.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, in Dublin,
everyone just had
a couple of pints at the pub
and then headed to a museum
to see the body of a man
who died in a bog
in 400 B.C.
[ Laughter ]
And in America we celebrate
by peeing in an ATM.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you so much.
I'm Nat Towson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There we go. Thank you, bud.
Nat Towson, everybody.
Thank you very much.
That was amazing.
I appreciate it.
Let's meet
contestant number two.
What is your name
and where are you from?
-I'm Allison Reese,
and I am from Mesa, Arizona.
-Hey, Arizona.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright. Can you tell
everyone what your topic is?
-Yes. Spring break.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright, bud. This is good.
Arizona's got some good spring
breaking out there.
They got some good party
schools.
-Yeah. ASU.
-ASU, exactly.
-They're so into it.
-Yeah, exactly.
Alright, get over. Get ready.
Get in your headspace.
Be prepared.
Thank you for doing this and
let me know when you're ready.
Okay. Channel the zone.
Channel the inspiration.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ladies and gentlemen, here
to perform a brand-new comedy
set about spring break is
the one and only Allison Reese!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes. Thank you. Thank you.
Yes. I've never been
a spring break person.
You know? I'm really more
of a "Kohl's Cash counts
as real money" kind of a person,
you know.
But Florida spring break
seems cool, right?
They got beaches,
drinking, gators.
That pet possum with lipstick
on it.
Florida's got all your spring
break needs, you know.
If I ever went
to a spring break concert,
though, I think I'd want
to see Maroon 5.
[ Crowd cheers ]
Yeah, right? Yeah.
But I want to see Maroon 5
solely
because I think that the guy
in Maroon 5 sounds like if
for the last five years, Elmo
has been taking testosterone.
[ Laughter ]
You know?
Like, can't you hear it?
[ High-pitched voice]
♪ And she will be loved ♪
♪ Tap on my window,
knock on my door ♪
[ As Elmo ] Elmo want to make
you feel beautiful.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That tickles.
[ Normal voice ] Oh, man, you
can't tell me that guy
doesn't sound like Elmo.
[ Laughter ]
Later you're going to be
listening to Maroon 5,
and you're going
to be like, "Elmo?
Elmo, your voice dropped."
Honestly, it's the only
spring break concert
I'm spending
my Kohl's Cash on, so yeah.
Thank you so much.
I'm Allison Reese.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on, Allison!
Allison Reese once again.
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
Now it is time
to see who won.
So we're going to let our great
audience decide the winner.
[ Drum roll ]
Was it Nat Towson?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Or was it Allison Reese?
The winner is Alison Reese!
Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You'll be going home --
You'll be going home
with an
"I love jokes" sweatshirt.
Congratulations.
-Oh, man.
-Yes. Congratulations.
You also take
a Tonight Show notebook
for writing more comedy
and $1,000 cash.
Come on, bud. Allison Reese,
thank you so much.
But no one goes home
empty-handed.
Our other contestant will also
get an "I love jokes"
sweatshirt.
There you go.
Nat, you deserve it.
And a Tonight Show notebook
and $1,000.
Give it up for two new instant
stand-up comedians.
Stick around. We'll be right
back with Tessa Thompson.
Come on back, everybody.